[Music]  Ashley I can Eddie and Jared hey bond  pack on the PDA in Hawaii the person I  wanted to be with most was ready for the  mais bachelor nation stars who announced  they are officially an item last week  wasted no time jetting off to Maui on a  romantic getaway over the holiday  weekend and the pair have been  documenting every sweet moment on social  media kisses by the pool romantic  dinners and hilarious Justin Timberlake  lip-sync sessions the 30 year old  reality star also shared with fans  Jared surprised her with a romantic  beach date in true bachelor fashions  Ashley couldn't help but gush over her  man  pouring champagne writing on the video  he needs to be cloned for womankind he  tells me every day that he's the  luckiest man alive and but my my dad my  mom that after 40 years